GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
WELCOME TO TODAY'S COMMITTEE ON
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY I JOIN ME ON THE DIESS
TODAY AT THE MOMENT WE HAVE OUR
VICE CHAIR WITH ME AND ALSO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. ARE WE DO
HAVE ONE TEMPORARY APPOINTMENT
FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT IS A
MEMBER OF THE UP WITH THE WALK
WAS FILLING A VACANT POSITION.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT TONY SIMONS AND ARE
WE ALSO HAVE OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS POLICY UNIT AS WELL
GENICULATE GILLAN'S. LET ME GO
TO REFUTE TO CONSENT AGENDA WE
HAVE FOR BILLS ON CONSENT ITEM
ONE AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN.
HOLLY ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SIX PETRIE-NORRIS AB
EIGHT. I MEAN EXCUSE ME ITEM H.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO A
JUDGE A BILL AND ITEM NINE AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR JODY
BUILD. MEMBERS I DO WANT TO DRAW
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE LIST OF
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WHICH YOU EACH HAVE A
COPY AT YOUR DESK. BEFORE WE
BEGAN OUR COMMITTEE BILL
PRESENTATION I NEED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF HOW THE PUBLIC
WILL BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING. DID THAT DO TO THE
PANDEMIC WE'RE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGING US TO BE WORN IN
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WE DO HAVE A
FEW OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFYING TO BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND I WILL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. FOR DIALING WITNESSES WE
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC CAN
TESTIFY ON THE BILL THE NUMBER
TO CALL IN. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING THEM PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
BILL PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE YOU MAY BE ASKED BY
THE MODERATOR TO IDENTIFY
WHETHER YOU WE WILL BE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING AND
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THAT INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST OR YOUR
SMARTPHONE DEVICES TO REDUCE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE AND WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS
BEFORE WE BEGIN TO HEAR ITEM.
FILE ITEM ONE I NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY SIMPLY HAS
INCREASINGLY EXPERIENCE A NUMBER
OF DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE OF
FOR PROCEEDINGS CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED. BOTH
NO TALK MONOIDS IS FROM AUDIENE
PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE PROVIDED
ONLY AT THE DESIGNATED TIME AND
PLACE AS PERMITTED BY THE CHAIR
PUBLIC COMMENT MUST RELATE TO
THE SUBJECT OR BILLS BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY NO ENGAGING IN
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE EARLY
CON THE BUSINESS TODAY. THEY
WERE ABOUT VIOLATE OF THESE
RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVE
OR OTHERWISE ENFORCEMENT PROCESS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION.
ALL RIGHT WE CAN START AS A- WE
DON'T SUB COMMITTEE SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE QUORUM YET SO LET ME
GO AHEAD.
SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN IF I COULD PASS THE
GAVEL TO OUR VICE CHAIR. SO I
COULD PRESENT THANK YOU.
OKAY CHAIR IF YOU ARE READY YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND MAKE A
PRESENTATION I'M GONNA BEGIN THE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN HUNDRED AUDIO
DOOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LET ME FIRST ACCEPTED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED AND
K. TWELVE THE ANALYSIS AB TWENTY
FOUR MODIFIES THE FORMAT CAPITAL
ACCESS PROGRAM CAL CAP. CAN FOR
THE ONE. ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL STATE SMALL
BUSINESS CREDIT INITIATIVES S.
S. B. C. I. FUNDS MORE
SPECIFICALLY THESE AMENDMENTS
TI<c.cyan> PROGRAM TARGETING CREDIBLE</c>
TRANSPARENT- AND ADDRESS NEED
FOR THE STATE TO PLAN NOW FOR
WHAT HAPPENS TO THAT SPENDING AT
THE CONCLUSION OF THE S. S. B.
C. I. PROGRAM. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT FUNDS BE TAMED FOR MEETING
THE NEEDS OF THE STATE'S MOST R.
CAPITAL CHALLENGED SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ME TOO. IS MORE
WITH THE SMALL BUSINESS OF KOREA
WHO'S HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. EIGHT MADAM CHAIR
CHAIR. OF LAURIE KAMMER I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING- YOU KNOW ON
THIS ISSUE- IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT. OUR ACCESS TO CAPITAL
GETS INTO THE HANDS OF THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO TRULY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE CAPITAL TO. A
THEIR BUSINESS OR GROW THEIR
BUSINESS. AND USUALLY IN THERE
THE RANGE. WOULD HELP A SMALL
BUSINESS IS BETWEEN FIVE
THOUSAND AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO IT'S A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT- A. B. BUT IN TERMS
OF. WHAT SMALL BUSINESSES CAN
QUALIFY- YOU KNOW WITH SORRY
ABOUT THE MASS THERE- IN TERMS
OF WHAT SMALL BUSINESSES CAN
QUALIFY FOR WITH THE BANKS A LOT
OF THE BANKS ARE LOOKING AT THE-
LANDING. LAW COMES OF THIS
BUSINESSES BUT REALLY START UP
COMPANIES AND MICRO BUSINESSES
ARE LOOKING AT- YOU DON'T HAVE
THE LOWER DOLLARS AND SO WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED AND TO THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND-
WE ARE CHAIR AYE VOTE. DO YOU
HAVE ANY US. SUPPORT WITNESS
HERE. IF NOT THE IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF W. IF
NOT THE MODERATOR IDEA ANY ONE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IF
YOU'RE INTO PART OF THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE TO YOU
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU FOR ANY
ONE- HERE. IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. MISSING NONE- MODERATOR
ANYONE NOT ONLINE IN A POSITION
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU A
MODERATOR- LET'S ASK OUR
MEMBERS- MIST- SO MAYBE IF THEY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. NO BIG ROLE
AND HAVE A PLATFORM AND THEN
WILL ALSO REFER TO. DO WE HAVE A
QUORUM HOW MAY NEED TO WE NEED.
OKAY. YEAH CALL. CERVI YOUR
CERVANTES VICE CHAIR CHOI HERE
HYSTER HERE PETRIE-NORRIS HERE
PETRIE-NORRIS HERE RAMOS SMITH
SMITH HERE YEP WHAT WHAT. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM OKAY GOOD THE IS
THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE BILL
. OKAY I SECOND- OKAY IT GAVE
ANY CLOSING STATEMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OKAY BUDGET CLOAK- WOULD YOU
PLEASE SO CALDERON- THE MOTION
IS- TO PASS- THE BILL OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE. TWO FOUR ZERO ZERO
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CERVANTES HI
CERVANTES FIVE VICE CHAIR CHOI I
BY SECURE CHOI HI PETRIE-NORRIS
- NORRIS HI RAMOS SMITH. WITH HI
THERE BE A TO A. OKAY SO
THEREFORE THE REMAINING MEMBERS-
ONLY BE DON'T KNOW OPEN UNTIL IT
IS YOUR NUMBER ITEM NUMBER SIX
I'M GONNA MAKE REMINDED
PRESENTATION. I WILL HANDLE THAT
AS WELL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS I'M GOING TO
DEFER TAKING THE ARE THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED INCOME AT
NINE WITH THE NEW GUIDANCE
GUIDELINES OUT LAST WEEK I WANT
MORE TIME TO CONSIDER HOW WE
MOVE FORWARD AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO MODIFIES THE SURF
PROGRAM TO CLEARLY CLARIFY
CERTAIN THE IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES AS WELL AS CALLING OUT
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
IN ORDER TO HAVE AN INCLUSIVE
ECONOMIC COMMUNITY AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANT PROGRAM. AMONG
OTHER CHANGES THE BILL BANS ON
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT COMPONENTS
OF THE REGIONAL ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PLANS TO SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDE CAREER PATHWAYS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH LESS THAN A TWO
YEAR DEGREE THE CURRENT PROGRAM
COULD BE INTERPRETED AS ONLY
SERVING THOSE WORKERS WHO ARE
ALREADY SCHEDULED TO BE IN HIGH
JOBS. IT ADDS ADDITIONAL
REPORTING THE LEGISLATURE
TRANSPARENCY TO THE PUBLIC ON
PROGRAM OUTCOMES WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY BY PHONE- IS MIKE-
WAYNE BURKE WITH CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD. I UNDERSTAND
HIS ARM ON THE LINE ON HOLD.
YEAH MY MOM MY CARL WEINBERG IS
SO IN SUPPORT OF THE WORLD THEY
ARE ONLINE MIGHT MY CAR IF YOU
ARE READY YOU CAN BEGIN. WHAT MY
MOMENT. RIGHT OR LOOKING FOR HIS
LINE NOW.
OKAY WHEN MY GUYS ALREADY LET ME
KNOW AS A- J. FOR SUPPORT THE
WITNESS OUT IS THE- WANTED-
MODERATE OR GO ONLINE- ASKING
IF- THERE ARE MANY. SUPPORTERS
SAW ON ON ON RYE. ONE MOMENT IF
MIKE IS I'M ONLINE PLEASE PRESS
. SHARES ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE THAT IS
ON TO SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. IN THE
IN THE MEANTIME A LOT. I'M SORRY
. YEAH WELL WE ARE WAITING FOR
ANY WITNESSES- ONLINE- IN THE
ROOM ANYONE IS SUPPORTIVE YOU
CAN LINE UP AND TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF WHAT OPPOSE. I YOU
HAD ONE PERSON ON THE PHONE LINE
. OKAY GO AHEAD. LINE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NUMBER
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND TWELVE IF YOU'D WISH TO
SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. M. A. R. I. TO Q. THE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY- YOU CAN NEVER TO
NOTIFY ANYONE IS ALREADY AND-
ANYONE NOT IN THE ROOM IS SIMPLE
OPPOSITION YOU CAN OUR LINE UP A
AND- WE HAVE A PERSON HERE. IN
SUPPORT GO AHEAD. DAVID NELSON
HERE DIRECTOR IN THIS CASE RIVER
REPRESENTING THE SACRAMENTO
ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO. AND.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND- I DON'T HEAR AN ONLINE
KNOW WHAT THE- MAJOR SUPPORT THE
WITNESS- ANYBODY DOWN SO- I.
WILL CLOSE. THEY ARE IN THE US
SUPPORT TO OPPOSE OPPORTUNITIES
STATEMENTS- AND THEN ON OUT OF
THE BACK TO OUR MEMBERS OF FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR WHAT
DISCUSSIONS. OKAY YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT TODAY. OKAY MOTION HAS
BEEN MADE THE- AND THE SECONDED-
TO PASS OUT OF THIS- COMMITTEE-
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. GO
AHEAD AB TWO THREE FOUR TO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR CERVANTES CHAU. A VICE
YOU'RE CHOI HI LAST YEAR CHOI
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS FIVE
RAMOS SMITH. SMITH HI VEHICLE
WEBER. I'LL CALL. YEAH THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SURCHARGE I DON'T WANT. WE
CAN GO AHEAD AND MOVE FORWARD
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE WE'RE
HEARING I AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE BY MR JONES SAWYER
RELATING TO THE T. CAC AND DI
DIVERS ARE CONTRACTORS BEFORE
THE AUTHOR BEGAN THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. LET ME GIVE
EVERYONE NOTICE THAT THE PHONE
LINES ARE NOT OPEN FOR WITNESSES
TO GET IN THE QUEUE. MR JOHNSON
WHERE UNDERSTAND YOU WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IDENTIFIED IN COMMENTS SIX THE
BILL ANALYSIS I. HAPPILY WILL
ACCEPT THE COMMENTS- INDEED THE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. IT'S A MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL WE ARE. WE WILL
ADOPT THOSE AMENDMENTS MISTER
JONES ARE YOU IN BEGAN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY ACT
CALIFORNIA'S MAKES SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN RECENT
YEARS UNFORTUNATELY THESE
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
LIMITED TO DEVELOPERS THAT DO
NOT ALWAYS REFLECT. OUR STATE'S
RICH RACIAL AND ETHNIC DIVERSITY
AT THE STAND THE INDUSTRY BY AND
LARGE HAS NOT MADE A CONSCIOUS
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT MORE
DIVERSE AND WOMEN OWNED FIRMS
HAVE ACCESS TO DEVELOPMENT
RELATED CONTRACTS. IT IS TIME
THE INDUSTRY COMES TOGETHER TO
CREATE SHARED GOALS AND METRICS
THAT CENTER ON RACE EQUITY AND
INCLUSION WHILE TRYING TO
OVERCOME THE ONGOING HOUSING
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA. AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE CALIFORNIA
TOWARD GREATER DIVERSITY BIKE
REQUIRING HOUSING SPONSORS THAT
RECEIVE AN ALLOCATION OF LOW
INCOME TAX CREDITS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE D. C. A. C. REPORT ON
THE USE OF WOMEN MINORITY
DISABLED VETERAN AND L. G. B. T.
Q. BUSINESS ENTERPRISES. THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
CREATE AND SHARE A DETAILED AND
VERIFIABLE PLAN TO INCREASE
DIVERSE PROCUREMENT THROUGH AN
ANNUAL REPORT TO THIS BODY AND
THE PUBLIC. LONG TERM GOALS FOR
ACHIEVING MORE DIVERSITY AMONG
THE BUSINESSES THEY CONTRACT
WITH MEMBERS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
WHO NEED IT MOST. BY DIVERSE
FIRMS THAT ARE MORE LIKELY TO
TAKE A PEOPLE CENTERED APPROACH
THAT I FOR HOW PROJECTS CAN
BENEFIT IN UP LIFT TO SURROUND
UNITY. AB SEVENTY THREE WILL
PROVIDE CRUCIAL DATA TO THIS
BODY THAT WILL ASSIST IN
CRAFTING NEW HOUSING POLICIES
CENTER AROUND DIVERSITY EQUITY
AND INCLUSION. I AM JOINED BY
COSPONSORED CONSTANTINE HATCHER
WOULD CALIFORNIA'S U. M. B. AND-
THAT TOO NEW TO KNOW A THRASH.
INTO WITH THE CENTER FOR THE
LATEST THREE OH. OVER THE PHONE
. BECAUSE WE MAY NOT HEAR FROM
HER OVER THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT MR HATCHER YOU CAN BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
EXCUSE ME THANK YOU UP CHAIR
CERVANTES AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR HEARING THE BILL TODAY I
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
AUTHORING. OUR BILL. IT'S
CONSTANT STATURE SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF COMMUNITY IMPACT FOR
CALIFORNIA YIMBY NONPROFIT
ORGANISED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO MAKING OUR STATE
AND AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE
WORK AND RAISE A FAMILY. TO
ALLEVIATE OUR FOR A HOUSING
CRISIS. SENATE INVESTMENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
HAS BEEN DEPLOYED IN FACT FIFTY
TWO BILLION. ALONE BETWEEN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY
WE ALSO KNOW CALIFORNIA NEEDS
ABOUT THREE TIMES THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THE CONSTRUCTION WORK
FORCE THEN AND NOW HAS TO BUILD
THE HOMES WE NEED. HOWEVER
BUSINESSES OWNED BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND OTHER MINORITIES HAVE
NOT SHARED IN THESE DEVELOPMENT
RESOURCES AT A RATE EQUIVALENT
TO OUR STATE'S RICH DIVERSITY
OVER THE YEARS THIS HAS LED TO
DIVERSE FIRMS LOSING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN POTENTIAL CONTRA. THE
RIVERS MISSED OUT AN OPPORTUNITY
TO EARN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
WEALTH AND THOUSANDS OF LIFE
CHANGING JOBS IF THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WAS AS
DIVERSE AS CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
COULD EXPECT APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY TWO POINT FOUR BILLION IN
PAYROLL INVESTMENTS ALONE.
IMAGINE THE IMPACT THESE
RESOURCE COULD HAVE A SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ARE JUST INCENTIVIZING OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUILDERS TO
BE MORE INTENTIONAL ABOUT WHO
THEY'RE HIRING. AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE IS A FIRST STEP
ADDRESSING THIS TRAGIC AND- THE
UP. DR SHOWN ECONOMIC JUSTICE
AND PER TRANCE. AROUND RACIAL
INEQUITIES WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
BY TRACKING SUPPLIER DIVERSITY.
BY DIVERSIFYING THE PIPE. PEOPLE
WHO SHARE IN THE REVENUE
RESULTING FROM THESE VITAL
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS WE CAN
INCREASE WEALTH THE MONTHS
COMMUNITIES TYPICALLY EXIT
EXCLUDED FROM SUCH VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITIES. SIMULTANEOUSLY
NURTURING DIVERSE CONSTRUCTION
AND DEVELOPMENT SUPPLY FROM TO
HELP INCREASE THE VOLUME OF
DESPERATELY NEEDED CONSTRUCTION
DESIGN ENGINEERING AND OTHER
RELATED FIRMS OPERATING
SUCCESSFULLY ACROSS THE STATE.
UPLIFTING DIVERSE FIRMS AND
WORKERS WILL HELP INCREASE THE
ANNUAL NUMBER OF HOMES BUILT IN
CALIFORNIA. END HELP FINANCIALLY
EMPOWER COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
HAVE LONG BEEN SHUT OUT A PAST.
UPWARD MOBILITY AND PROSPERITY
THIS HELPS WITH THE WORK FORCE
IN A WAY THAT ENCOURAGES RACE
EQUITY. HELPING SOLVE OUR
OVERALL SUPPLY SHORTAGE IN A WAY
THAT ALSO ADVANCES GOOD JOBS FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN IN THOSE
FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS THIS IS
WHY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA MEAN
OR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS
AND AFFILIATED. ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE I HUMBLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. MISTER MODERATOR I
BELIEVE WE HAVE MISS RUSSIAN
ATTACK ON THE CONFERENCE LINE
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE. ANYONE ON
THE CONFERENCE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SAN
FRANCISCO AGAIN WOULD BE- IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO EIGHT SEVEN
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS ADAM BRYANSTON CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOUNG AND IF
ANYONE ELSE IS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THERE ARE AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
I DO HAVE ONE PERSON WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT.
NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS CARLA
BASKET BUDDY I GOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL INITIATIVES
SUPPORT CORPORATION LOS ANGELES
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THERE'S NO ONE I
THINK YOU AT THIS TIME. LET ME
ALSO PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. GOOD MORNING I
KARINA MARTINEZ REPRESENTING
KENYA I'M GOING STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO- IS THERE ANYONE WHO LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF THIS
BILL WHO'S WITH US TODAY IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM.C. NINE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
. RIGHT IT IF YOU'RE NOT WITH
THE FACT FINDING. ONE NINE ZERO.
IS THERE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION ON. WE HAVE NO ONE
AND I FOUND NINE. WE'LL MADRE
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO TRY ONE
MORE TIME TO- IDENTIFY IF THERE
IS A PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
. TO THIS BILL WE GET. WE ID
HAVE THAT PERSON ONLINE THEY
HAVE DISCONNECTED THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE CONFERENCE LINE WHO
IS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU EXPERIENCE
THAT PART OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND
MY MOM AND WE DO HAVE ONE WITH
AN OPERATOR.
ONE MOMENT. NINE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD MORNING ADD
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THIS
YEAR THE NEW ARTHUR ASHE IN
TRUCK THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
THE CARE THAT YOU'VE TAKEN TO
ENSURE THAT I HAVE A CHANCE.
TODAY WWW DOT- DON'T COME RECORD
MY VOICE AND I AM UNDER THE
WEATHER. ALL BUT INFO RELATED TO
A TWENTY EIGHT SEVEN THREE I'M
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK ARE THE
PRIMARY BUSINESS THE COURT OF
THE LEGISLATION. I DON'T THINK.
THEM JONES SAWYER WELL. FOR HIS
LEADERS AND OFFERING BILL. I
CURRENTLY SERVE THE PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE CENTER BY
L'INDUSTRIE IT IS A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
ENSURING THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
HAVE ACCESS TO THE TECHNICAL AND
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO CRIED. BUT BOTH
RECENTLY THIRD AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A LOCAL INITIATIVES
SUPPORT CORPORATION LOS ANGELES.
UNDER WHICH ATTACKED NINE WHERE
IN A POSITION PAPER THAT BROUGHT
FORTH THIS LEGISLATION. YOU HAVE
READ BEFORE YOU TODAY. AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS PIONEERED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NOW FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE. I THINK WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT EVEN
PROJECT YES THANK YOU BYE THE
CALIFORNIA TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SPEND AROUND FIFTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS BETWEEN THE YEARS TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY. WE
CONTINUE BECAUSE OF OUR HOUSING
CRISIS TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
BUILD THE NECESSARY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN OUR COMMUNITY. THIS
IS THE EVENT TAKING PLACE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ABOVE THE STATE
LEVEL. YET OF ALL OF THOSE
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN UTILIZED
IN ORDER TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. BUT WE KNOW THAT
APPROXIMATELY 6275% OF THOSE
DOLLARS ARE DISCRETIONARY
MEANING THE DEVELOPER HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DIRECT THOSE
RESOURCES. TO A DIVERSE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND TO A WIDER RANGE
OF SMALL BUSINESSES THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TODAY. WE'VE HAD
A CHANCE TO HOLD FOCUS GROUPS
AND- WHAT ABOUT HELP DEVELOPERS
ABOUT UTILIZING RESOURCES THAT
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
DIRECT HIM AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
THE MORE DIVERSE FIRMS WITHIN
OUR STATE. MANY OF THEM HAVE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT AND ARE EAGER
TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO TRY AND
ADDRESS RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
EQUITY THROUGH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING. I URGE
YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
POSITION PAPER THAT OUTLINES.
ALL OF THE VARIOUS- RESOURCES
THAT ARE NEEDED IN ADDITION TO
THIS PARTICULAR BILL IN ORDER TO
BRING FORTH A MORE RESOURCES.
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND
BUSINESSES AND WE LOOKED ABOUT
THE HOUSING CRISIS. THE FOURTEEN
DAY AT YOU ON BEHALF. BY
L'INDUSTRIE ASSEMBLY REQUEST
BOAT IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THERE HAS BEEN
A MOTION IS VERY SECOND. SO ALL
SECONDS THE BILL TODAY I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT- IT IS NOTED THAT
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY THREE IS
DUE PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
AS YOU CAN SEE THERE WAS THERE'S
THIRTEEN PAGES OF ANALYSIS- THE
HAVE BEEN COMPILED A THANK YOU
TO OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT ARE FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL TO
GET IT TO WORK OUT TODAY- SO
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT WITH- THOSE
AMENDMENTS. WITH THE CHIEF BUT
BUT ME TURNING BACK TO MR JONES
SAWYER TURNED BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DOES ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE WISH TO ASK QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR. C. NINE OF MISTER
JONES OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
. ALSO WON A THANK YOU NOTE YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF THE CEMEX
NETWORK AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
DO THIS RIGHT. AND I WANTED TO
THANK THEM FOR THE CONSTITUTION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOUR FOR A WE COULD HAVE
OUR TO CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SURE CERVANTES AREN'T
YOUR CERVANTES HI VICE CHAIR
CHOI. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY PEACHY
NORRIS I ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH NO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF AIRPORT FOOD LAST. ALSO NOT
BILL IS ON CALL AND I'M SURE IS
MEMBERS COMMENDABLE WILL BE
ADDED TO THE ROLE RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE. MEMBERS
LET'S MOVE TO THE NEXT AGENDA
ITEM ON FILE. WE HAVE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY NINETEEN
WILL BE HEARING FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS RELATING TO
THE SMALL BUSINESS AND
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES BEFORE THE AUTHOR
BEGINS OUR BILL PRESENTATION LET
ME. GIVE EVERYONE NOTICES THE
PHONE LINES ARE NOT OPEN FOR
WITNESSES TO GET INTO THE QUEUE.
I MISS SPEECH IN OUR CENTER SO
YOU'LL BE ACCEPTING TODAY'S
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED
IN COMMENTS ELEVEN OF THE BILL
ANALYSIS. YES AT VERY HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND I WANT TO THANK.
YOU AND YOUR TEAM FOR YOUR YOUR
WORK ON NOT ON THIS PROPOSAL.
GOT CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE THE HEART AND SOUL OF OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY THE HEART AND
SOUL OF OUR COMMUNITIES I KNOW
OF SO MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN A PASSION
ADVOCATES FOR CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS SAYS. AND I
CALIFORNIA'S STATE BUDGET OUR
STATE CONTRACT TEAM REALLY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO. PUT OUR
MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS WHEN IT
COMES TO SUPPORTING THE GROWTH
OF CALIFORNIA'S SMALL
BUSINESSES. AB TWENTY NINETEEN I
WILL CODIFY. PERCENT PARK. PAUL
FIRST SAYS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX GOVERNORS WERE NEGATIVE
SIGNED EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTING
ALL STATE AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS
BOARDS COMMISSIONS TO ACHIEVE A
25% GOAL FOR SMALL BUSINESS
PARTICIPATION IN. AND TRY.
OFFICIALLY AND GOAL AS WELL AS
ESTABLISH ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE HITTING
TACKLE AND SUPPORTING SMALL
BUSINESS THIS BILL ALSO
IMPLEMENTED AND ECONOMIC EQUITY
FIRST PROVISION TO INCREASE THE
PARTICIPATION OF DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES AS PART OF
THAT 25% GOAL I THANK YOU NOW I
AM PLEASED TO INTRODUCE MY VERY
WHAT. IS TWENTY. THE COLLEGE AND
CHEAPER. MISTER NELSON PLEASE BE
ON WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING OOD MORNING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER A MORNING A
MORNING AT CHURCH CERVANTES
ADVICE HERE CHOI MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVID
NELSON I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY AT THE CALIFORNIA
ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND IT IS MY PLEASURE
TO BE HERE ONCE AGAIN ADVOCATING
FOR OUR SMALL AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES IN OUR GREAT STATE. I
WOULD LIKE TO- RECORD N. DEEPLY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY WOMAN COUNTY
PETRIE-NORRIS IS LEADERSHIP IN
AUTHORING THIS BILL WE'RE- SCOPE
THIS IS CO SPONSORED BY THE
CALLIE IN CALIFORNIA HISPANIC
AND THE CALIFORNIA AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHAMBER CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE HER THE SHIP AND
BRING THIS BILL CONCEPT BACK
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. WE ONCE
AGAIN STRIVE TO GET THIS WE
TALKED CODIFICATION INTO STATUTE
FOR OUR SMALL BUSINESSES I WOULD
SAY THAT THE STATUTORY GOAL IN
IT IN AND OF ITSELF- IS A GOAL
AND WOULD ADD ACCOUNT A BILL.
RIGHT MOBIS IS HERE FROM THE
STATE THAT THIS THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR ECONOMY. OVER THE YEARS WE-
WE HAVE ALL HEARD OVER AND OVER
AGAIN ABOUT HOW RESILIENT AND
STRONG OUR SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
ALMOST TO THE POINT THAT IT HAS
BECOME A CLICHE. BUT AS WE NOW
ENTER OUR THIRD PANDEMIC HERE.
WE HAVE SEEN JUST EXACTLY HOW
STRONG AND RESILIENT OUR
BUSINESSES ARE AND MOST HAVE
PIVOTED MORE THAN WE COULD'VE
EVER EXPECTED OF THEM AND STILL
SURVIVED. AND ONE OF THE WAYS
AND FRANKLY WHEN THE LIFELINES
FOR THESE PURPOSES IS FOR THEM
TO PIVOT TO THE STATE AS A
CUSTOMER. AND I THINK THIS BILL
GOES A LONG WAY IN SHOWING THAT
THE STATE WILL PIVOT TO THEM AS
A VENDOR AND PRIORITIZE THEM IN
THE PIPELINE. I'M FOR THE STATE
. TWENTY FIVE THIS IS
PROCUREMENT GOAL WE CANNOT TAKE
THE RESILIENCY AND PERSISTENCE
OF OUR SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS FOR
GRANTED ANY LONGER ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
THEIR SUCCESS IS OUR SUCCESS AND
WE NEED TO DELIVER FOR THEM NOW
AND THIS TIME. AS OUR SMALL
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
CONTINUE TO PIVOT TO THE STATE
WE NEED TO RESPECT THEIR
STRENGTH AND TO HONOR THEM IN
PASSING THIS BILL THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT YOU HAVE ON THIS
BILL IS VERY THOROUGH AND WE
APPRECIATE- DILLON CONSIDER OF
TONY. CAN PROVIDE NOW'S DO AS
YOU CAN SEE YOURSELF THE
MEASURES THIS BILL WILL ENACT TO
ENSURE THE STATE FOLLOWS WITH
ITS COMMITMENT. ALONG WITH. W.
IS OUT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
RURAL UNDERSERVED AND
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING AND WE DO ASK FOR
UNANIMOUS AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL
. THANK YOU MISTER NELSON DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORTING. DO YOU HAVE THAT
MANY IDEAS HERE THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. GOOD
MORNING- ARE BUILT SHARE THE
MEMBERS MANY D. AS REPRESENTING
THE UP CALIFORNIANS BANK
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE OR ALSO. A
CO SPONSOR WITH THE CALIBRATION
CHAMBER AS WELL AS THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
FOR US IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE THAT ARE YOU CAUGHT UP BY THE
25% GOAL FOR OUR DIVERSE SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
LONG OVERDUE. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE UPTICK KERMAN OPPORTUNITIES
THAT EXIST THROUGHOUT ALL STATE
AGENCIES IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT ARE. THAT ARE
INVESTING OUR COMMUNITIES YOU
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
INVESTMENT GOES TO THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE WORKING THAT
COMMUNITY. AND THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE DIVERSITY THAT WE
HAVE TALKED CALIFORNIA THAT'S
THE A- THERE'S STATE AGENCY. TO
A GOOD JOB INTO TO REACH. THAT
POINT BY POLITICAL AND IS QUITE
FRANKLY OTHER AGENCIES ARE NOT.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD CREATE AN
EQUITY PLAN IN ACTION PLAN
THAT'S VERY MUCH NEEDED. AND
WOULD ALSO HOLD THE AGENCY
ACCOUNTABLE AND ALSO THE PARTY
BACK TO YOU. SO FOR US THIS IS.
A VERY IMPORTANT CODIFIED. AT TO
DEVELOP THAT ACTION PINE SO
AGAIN WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. FOR DOING THIS BILL IN
OF COURSE OR THE- GREAT
ANALYSIS THAT YOU'RE COMING TO
PUT TOGETHER. YOU MISTER DE AS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CASEY O'CONNOR
ON BEHALF OF STATE TREASURER
FIONA MA IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
LAURIE CAMERON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER. SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
METALS COALITION. THIS IS THE
YEAR TO DO THIS. WE HAVE A VERY
STRONG AUTHOR WE HAVE A MAN WHO
IS. A COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
MINORITY WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES
WE STAND IN FULL SUPPORT WE URGE
OUR AYE VOTE. WILL GET UP. HELLO
TERRY MEMBERS RYAN ELAINE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING CAL NUMBER TINA'S
CAMEO- IN SUPPORT OF THE- THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE OUR MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU IF ANYONE IS
NOT. IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE IN A ROW. I DO I'M NOT SURE
I THINK THESE ARE THIS PERSON
MIGHT BE- ONE MOMENT. FIND
SEVENTEEN YOU KNOW LINE UP AND.
A LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE YOUNG BLONDE PRESS
WITH SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY BUT
WORK VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU. THEN WE HAVE
OUTLINED TWENTY FIVE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH HI. BEEN GOING BACK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALSO IN SUPPORT. THEY
HAVE LINE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK RUNNING CAN BE A
LITTLE BOTH THE CREEK DRIVE G.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALPERS BOARD
ACTION IN SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
WON WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER THAT VARY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION OFTEN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
FURTHER OPERATIVE SYSTEM THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MODERATOR MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
OPEN IT UP FOR DISCUSSION FOR
MISTER SMITH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AS A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER CALIFORNIA
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS THIS IS
WHAT WE NEED- YOU'LL CONSIDER A
CO AUTHOR APPRECIATE THAT AND
I'LL GO AHEAD MAKE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AND NOT BE
PLEASED TO HAVE YOU JOIN ON AS A
CO AUTHOR. SO MEMBERS I DO-
WANTED JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADOPT THESE AMENDMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION- I TO JUST WANT TO
SEE. THIS IS A LONG OVERDUE.
THANK A THE AUTHOR FOR. PURSUING
THIS AND REALLY FIGHTING
ADVOCATING FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND ALL THOSE WHO
SPOKE IN SUPPORT TODAY. HI THIS
IS THE YEAR TO DO IT. AS IT WAS
SEND IT BY ONE OF. HELLO ONE OF
OUR SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANY FURTHER COMMENT. MEMBERS
SEEN NONE- IF. OUR MISS PEACH
PURSUE LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR HI AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I'VE- BUDGET CONSULTANT. AB
TWO OH ONE NINE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR CERVANTES HI YOUR
CERVANTES III VICE CHAIR CHOI
VICE CHAIR CHOI HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS I REMEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS SAID. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VIA FOOD WHAT. THE BILL IS ON
PAUL. AND WE'LL LET THE COPY AND
- AT THE END OF COMMITTEE. WE DO
HAVE ITEM NUMBER FOUR NACS AB
TWENTY THREE FOURTEEN FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
RELATING TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
LOAN GUARANTEE BROWN THE CAP
SAYS PROGRAM BEFORE THE AUTHOR
BEGINS BY ME GO AHEAD AND GIVE
NOTICE TO THOSE IN THE QUEUE THE
LINES ARE NOW OPEN- THIS FEATURE
NORRIS YOU CAN BEGAN WHEN YOU'RE
READY RIGHT. THANK YOU. I AM.
TELL 23-14 TODAY FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO AGAIN THANK- COMMITTEE
STAFFER YOUR WORK ON THIS AND TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH PROTECTIONS FOR
BORROWERS PARTICIPATING IN THE
STATE TREASURER'S CAL CAP AND I
BANKS SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAM AB 23-14
BUILDS UPON PAST WORK TO ENSURE
THAT TRANSPARENT PRICE. IS I
THANK LANDS THIS BILL REQUIRES
LENDERS THAT UTILIZE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS THROUGH CAL CAP AND THE
SMALL BUSINESS LOAN GUARANTEE
PROGRAM. TO ABIDE BY SEVERAL IN
BURTON PERRANCE HE PROVISIONS IT
IS VITAL THAT. WHEN HUNDREDS ARE
UTILIZING TAXPAYER DOLLARS THEY
ARE DOING SO FAIRLY I'M NOW
PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES I CAROLINA MARTINEZ
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR MICRO ENTERPRISE
OPPORTUNITIES TRINITY CAMEO AND
MICHAEL RAPAPORT FRIEND AXION
OPPORTUNITY FUND. ONE THANK YOU-
ADAM TURBINES CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CAROLYN
MARTINEZ AND I REPRESENT KENYA-
WE ARE STATEWIDE OUR NETWORK OF
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ORGAN AGENTS DEDICATED TO
FURTHERING MICRO AND SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT IN
CALIFORNIA FINALLY OUR MEMBERS
SERVE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
VERY SMALL BUSINESSES WITH
TRAINING BUSINESS AND CREDIT
ASSISTANCE AND LOANS THESE FIRMS
. HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS. AND
GENERATE A TOTAL OF SEVEN POINT
FIVE BILLION IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY. ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA
HAS A ROBUST NETWORK OF
DEVELOPED MICRO BUSINESS AS
ASSISTANT ORGANIZATIONS A REPORT
FROM THE FEDERAL RESERVE'S
INDICATED THAT 85% OF A SMALL
BUSINESSES EXPERIENCE FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. UP NEARLY 20% FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN IT ALSO FOUND THAT
INDIVIDUALS OF COLOR ARE MORE
LIKELY TO GO ONLINE TO FILE. AND
THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS IS
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE LOOKING FOR
CAPITAL THAT WILL HELP THEM
REBUILD FROM THE PAIN THAT MAKE
THERE WERE. PRICE WE ANY OF YOU
LOAN THAT SOMETIMES ARE NOT WHAT
THEY SEEM AT THE MALL MALIBU'S
BARKER'S CASE THE EAST BAY
BORDER WITH TOP WAS UNABLE TO
GET A TRADITIONAL BANK LOAN AND
TOOK OUT WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS A
REGULAR LOAN FROM AN ONLINE
LENDER HOWEVER THE FINANCING WAS
REALLY AYE RECEIVABLES PURCHASE
AGREEMENT WITH DALY DEDUCTIONS
FROM THEIR BANK ACCOUNT. THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN OWNER HAS
EXPRESSED PUBLICLY HOW HIS WHITE
COUNTERPARTS WERE RECEIVING MORE
ATTRACTIVE CAPITAL OFFERS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT THE
SOLUTION I KNOW HE OWNED AND
WOMEN OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES AS
WELL AS ENTREPRENEURS OF COLOR
WITH THE COMPLETE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO MAKE. TELL THE WAY
NATIONWIDE WITH RESPONSIBLE IS
SMALL BUSINESS LENDING WITH SB
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE THE TRUTH IN
LENDING BILL. THIS IS THE MOMENT
TO GO FOR THEIR WITH AB TWENTY
THREE FOURTEEN BY CODY FIND
SEVERAL BEST PRACTICES IN THE
SMALL BUSINESS LENDING AND
MAKING SURE THAT ANY FUNDING
SUBSIDIZED BY THE STATE. IS
DON'T BUY IT FULL LENGTH. YOU
KNOW LIKE NOW TO INTRODUCE
MICHAEL RAPAPORT FROM EXTENDED
PATERNITY FUND I THINK HE'S ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU MISS
MARTINEZ OUR MODERATOR I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE MISTER RUFF
BEFORE ON THE LINE WITH US.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CERVANTES VICE
CHAIR CHORE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY
COLLEAGUE MICHAEL RAPAPORT COULD
NOT ATTEND BUT I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE OUR ORGANIZATION EIGHTY
TWO THREE ONE FOUR. MANY WRONG
AND I THE POLICY COMMUNICATION
MANAGER NOT. AND OUR PANEL WHICH
ON A LOT COMMITTEE MOMENT.
CONDITION WORKING YOUR CREATING
. HEALTHY FINDING SYSTEM THAT
SUPPORTS OUR NATION SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. WE DO THIS I
CAN ENTREPRENEURS AFFORDABLE.
EDUCATION RESOURCES COACHING
ATHLETICS. I'M SORRY WE SHOULD
SUPPORT FOR AND THEY WILL IN
BETWEEN IS NOW A BEACH THREE
ONE. THE WOULD REQUIRE ANY BY
PART OF VIRGIN STATE FARM
INCLUDE TRAVEL FROM RIGHT
PROTECTION OF OUR.
TREE WE'RE ALSO USING SMALL
BUSINESS WONDER IN THE STATE'S
CAL CAP AND I THINK ONE
GUARANTEE PROGRAM. IN FACT WE
HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE TAKIKO
CALENDARS FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE WHAT THIS
PUBLICADOS I RESPONSIBLE ANY
PRACTICES LIKE THE BANNING OF
THE USE OF PROFESSIONAL
JUDGMENT. IN THE STATE PROGRAMS.
AND SHOWING OFF THEIR RICHNESS
MODIFIERS CARDMEMBER ENDING
DON'T TALK ABOUT THE RESULT OF
NOT KNOWING OR UNDERSTANDING IN
TERMS OF THE FINANCIAL. WELCOME
GENERATION LANDLORDS AGENTS.
YEAH ABOUT A TWENTY FIVE ON THE
DOLLAR ON RUN ENDED UP YOUR OVER
TO THE DOLLARS MONTH. ALL
BECAUSE OF THE GARBAGE FEES.
BUCKLEY WERE ABLE TO HELP EVERY
. WHICH TIME OKAY IN JULY
DOLLARS A MONTH SUGGESTS. THE
END OF YOUR CAN IMPLEMENT.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE- MULTIPLE-
FINANCING CONTRACTS WITH
KNOWLEDGE ACQUIRE. I WAS ON
BALLOT YOU KERR WAS NINETY PUSH
. WITH ONE LOAN AMOUNT CHANGE
YEAR. BE ENTERED THE GATE
PERCENT. I JUST OF THE
PRODUCTION OPENING SOMEBODY
WOMEN PETRIE-NORRIS IS OVER.
BECAUSE THE STREET EVERY BE LEFT
BEFORE STORY. AB TWENTY ONE IS A
STEP ENSURING CHANCE.
RESPECTFULLY I AND I UNDERSTAND
. MY IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
LINE WHO LIKE TO SPEAK INTO OF
THIS. THANK YOU- IF YOU. WANT
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE ONE TO
ZERO AND DO HAVE LINE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE MY
BECAUSE THEY- FOR MOTHER MAJOR.
HUGE DATA WHICH YOU CAN CALL
THEM HELPING- THE BELL THANK YOU
A HUGE THANK ASSEMBLY. YOU NINE.
THING THAT IMPORTANT INITIATIVE
WERE DRAW SUPPORT OF THE OUR-
WITHIN THE PROVISION THANK YOU
MUCH. AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO. PROTESTS Q. AND FOR THOSE IN
THE CURRENT WOULD LIKE TO BE
SPEAKING SUPPORT SHOULD BE AS-
MANY AS A REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA THANK CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE. IN SUPPORT. MORNING
MEMBER IN TEARS UP COMMITTEE
MEMBER ENTERS LAURIE CAMERA
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS CALIFORNIA
pCALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA METALS
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CASEY O'CONNOR AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE TREASURE AND WE
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION YET
AT THIS TIME BUT I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK
ON. THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR
THEIR LEADERS THE INTENT HERE IS
GREAT AND I THINK WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON IT SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SEE NO ONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WITH THE
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE. ON IN THE HEARING ROOM
TODAY WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. C. N. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE CONFERENCE.
LINES WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND IF YOU
WANT TO BEGIN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND AT THIS
TIME DOES NOT WANT YOU IN UP.
LET ME GO AHEAD AND TURN IT TO
DISCUSSION- TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL PROVIDE
COMMENT. C. NINE AND LET ME GO
AHEAD AND- STATE SAY THANK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED AND
COMMENT ELEVEN OF THE BILL
ANALYSIS. I HAVEN'T HEARD A
MOTION WILL GO BACK. SO WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SOME PROGRESS IN THE
SECOND BY SOME MEMBER SMITH. IF
OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN PLEASE
LET ME TURN IT BACK OVER TO THE
AUTHOR FOR A MOMENT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE CLOSING COMMENTS
THANK YOU I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT ACCESS TO CAPITAL
IS AN ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
INGREDIENT TO BUILDING A
SUCCESSFUL SMALL BUSINESS. THE
REALITY IS THAT IT CAN BE
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO.
NAVIGATE THEY LOANS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TERMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND I ARE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WE'VE HEARD A
FEW EXAMPLES CAN FIND THEMSELVES
SUBJECT TO PRACTICES THAT ARE
DECEPTIVE AND DOWNRIGHT
PREDATORY. BUT THAT'S A PROBLEM
IN ALL CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED
BY TAXPAYER DOLLARS WE'VE GOT TO
ENSURE TRANSPARENCY WE'VE GOT IT
ENSURE FAIRNESS FOR CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES SO. I THINK YOU
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE- WE CAN GO AHEAD AND HAVE
THE ROLE. IN HERE. THE MEASURES
AB TWO THREE ONE FOR THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR CERVANTES HI SURE
CERVANTES AYE VICE CHAIR CHOI.
VICE CHAIR CHOI I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS HI DELIVER
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROSS. SIMILAR AROMAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SPENT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA FOOD
WHAT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THINK HERO. ALL. MEMBERS WE CAN
MOVE OUR TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
R. BY THE MOTION BY SMITH A
SECOND BYE BYE SURE CHOI THE
FOURTEENTH CONSULTED TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I CONSENT ITEM
ONE AB TWO EIGHT ONE NINE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ITEM FIVE AB TWO
THREE SEVEN SIX PETRIE-NORRIS
WITH AMENDMENTS THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ITEM EIGHT AB
TWO NINE SEVEN TWO THE MOTION IS
DUE TO APPROPRIATIONS. ITEM NINE
AB TWO NINE SEVEN FOR THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED THE PREPARATIONS.
SURE CERVANTES ARE YOUR
CERVANTES I VOICED VICE CHAIR
CHOI. BY CHAIR CHOI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS SILVER
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROB SOBRE ALMOST ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SPENT SUMMER SMITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VIA PUT A LOT. THAT
INCLUDES- CONCLUDES A BILL
PRESENTATION FOR THE DAY WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT CHECK IF THERE IS ANY
ITEM STILL ON CALL. ANY MEMBERS
CITY OUT ON IF WE CAN GO THROUGH
. FOR MEMBERS MADE OUT ON. WE
CAN START WITH AB. TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE. I AM TO TWENTY
SEVENTY THREE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. RAMOS I.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAW. RUBIO WHO
WALKED HIGH. THAT'S ABOUT. OKAY
THAT IS OUT SIX TWO ZERO. WHAT
DO PASSED WITH THE MOMENT YOUR
PREPARATION WE COULD TAKE UP AB
TWENTY NINETEEN TO PASS WITH THE
MOMENTS HERE PROBES. EIGHTY TWO
OH ONE NINE DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAMOS SO RAMOS I SOME OF OUR
REVIEW IF YOU'D WALKED. A
SIMILAR VEHICLE BLOCKED BY.
BURKE COUNTY SIX ZERO DOUBLES
OUT WE WILL NOT LIFT THE CALL ON
AB. TWENTY THREE FOURTEEN. THE
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS FOR
PREPARATIONS. AB TWENTY THREE
FOURTEEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS- TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- VIA FOOD WHAT.
BY A VOTE OF SIXTY ZERO BUT
THOSE OUT. WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO D.
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
PREPARATION OF THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB TWO THREE FOUR TO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. RAMOS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA TO FOOD WALK
SO AMERICA COULD WALK HIGH. BOTH
SIX TWO ZERO ABOUT BILLS OUT WE
HAVE FILE ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ALSO IT. YES THE FIRST. WELCOME
BACK FIRE. WHICH ITEM SO WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE A FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS SOME AROMAS HI SOME OF
REAL FOOD WHILE. SO VIA FOOD
WALK BY. THAT'S A VOTE OF SIX TO
ZERO THAT BILLS OUT LET'S GO
BACK AND GO TO ADD WE HAVE ONE
MORE BILL AND THEN A CONSENT-
THE CONSENT AGENDA FOR THOSE IT
OUT ON LET ME JUST TO TAKE CARE
CONSENT. FOR THOSE THAT NEED OUT
ON. THIS IS CONSENT IT INCLUDES
AB- ITEM ONE AB TWO EIGHT ONE
NINE. ITEM FIVE AB TWO THREE
SEVEN SIX ITEM EIGHT TO NINE
SEVEN TWO. AND ITEM NINE AB TWO
NINE SEVEN FOUR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VIA FOOD LAW. SOLOVIEV WHO WOULD
WALK BY.
RIGHT YEAH. CONFORM RIGHT YEAH.
THE DISTRIBUTOR MATHIS YEAH. SO
LET ME GO BACK AND RE STATE FILE
ITEM TO AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE NOT VOTE COUNT IS FOR NO
ONE NOT BILL IS OUT DUE PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS TO PREPARATIONS. FACEBOOK. I'M HERE NOW I
DISAGREE WITH YES NOW WE COSTS
ARE. YEAH.